hi welcome to Jupiter the MIT the fa IL  weather information system featuring WSI  corporations in telecast weather  forecast this call is being recorded for  system development you may hang up or  ask for help at any time how can I help  you what's the weather forecast for  Boston tomorrow in Boston Thursday  partly cloudy skies high 76 thursday  night partly cloudy skies in the evening  becoming cloudy skies overnight low 59  what other information can i give you is  it going to rain over the weekend  in boston saturday slight chance of a  thunderstorm sunday isolated  thunderstorm what other information can  i give you what's the weather like in  Taipei tonight  in Taipei tonight overcast with rain  showers at time low 73 fifty percent  chance of rain what other information  can I give you